I was elected to represent the citizens
of Pittsburgh not Paris
well that was President Trump as he
withdrew the u.s. from the Paris climate
Accord just a week later a new coal mine
opened about 60 miles outside Pittsburgh
the president said the climate deal was
unfair to America's coal industry Don
Dahler is inside the new mine in acosta
Pennsylvania with a look at weather it
signals a comeback for cold John good
morning good morning we are 120 feet
below ground and this is the entrance to
one of the mines they've just started
digging these and this is a brand-new
mine this is one of the big mining
machines that's digging into those coal
seams with these big teeth the material
being pulled out of these mines is
called metallurgical coal as opposed to
most of the coal that is mined in this
country that's using the production
electricity this coal is actually an
ingredient in the production of steel
but for the people in this area this
rock represents hope didn't feel for a
while that this was a dying industry yes
yes and there
a bleak thought for a place where coal
runs in the blood my grandfather's were
coal miners my my father was a coal
miner for a while Rob bata goal works
for corset coal he listened carefully to
candidate Trump's promises on the
campaign trail we're going to save that
coal industry believe me we're going to
save it what did it mean to you to hear
the commitment that he made to the coal
industry oh I think it felt great
because I you know gave people a little
more optimism and people had a little
more hope in the industry so that's the
coal seam right there courses new mine
was in the works before the election but
last week the president highlighted it
as a rare bright spot a big opening of a
brand new mine it's unheard of for many
many years that hasn't happened the coal
industry has lost more than a third of
its workforce over the past decade with
a 69 percent drop in the number of
active mines in the past 20 years it's
hard for me to see that coal is going to
recover
it's huge market share J apt is co
director of the Carnegie Mellon
electricity industry Center he says
steel producing coal represents just a
tiny fraction of the overall industry
and won't move the needle on the bigger
problem natural gas has eaten coals
market share it's gone down from 50
percent to 30 percent those coal mines
are unlikely to come back anytime soon
when it things get rough around here I'd
say in the 90s it started in the 90s
maybe where all the mines are shutting
down the steel mills were going out and
that's what the people worked here since
then Betty wrote hasn't had as many
hungry mouths to feed here at the coal
miners cafe the new mine is only hiring
seventy to a hundred workers but she's
bracing for business to pick up what is
the opening of this mine mean to this
community everybody's hoping its income
to everybody
down in the mine they're just happy to
finally be moving forward you think this
is the beginning of something I hope so
yes I think it will be maybe only 70
jobs but those 70 jobs being the world -
those 70 families there are about 51,000
coal miner jobs left in this country
which is why a lot of people were
surprised when the EPA Chairman Scott
Pruett announced that 50,000 jobs had
been added to the coal mining economy
there have been jobs at it but only
about a thousand Gail Don thank you